on this week's show is there going to be
a major market crash in the news why are
the government lettin off rorke
landlords and we're gonna be answering
all your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
EADS I'm Alistair Cunningham and welcome
to this week's property investors
podcast interesting week this way we're
gonna be talking about the crash and the
reason that we're gonna be talking about
that is because we had dinner a few days
ago with Robert Kiyosaki yeah we did we
were running an event
Samuel Leeds limited property investor
Samuel Leeds and success resources being
solve a joint event together yep
Samuel interviewed him on stage we had
dinner with him and one of the things
that we that was was interesting well
first of all did you enjoy the evening
before we go it was interesting he's one
of these characters that everyone knows
who's Robert Kiyosaki is if your improv
that you know who Robert Kiyosaki is
yeah author a Rich Dad Poor Dad
he's a very profound sort of investor he
knows what he's talking about he's been
around I think he's in his late 70s 72
72 okay and he's he's like a big
towering guy in tea he's a big old boy
and he big like route all he's got
presence about him yeah and oh he's
definitely got a presence about him yeah
ya know when he walks when he walks in
the room yeah I was speaking with some
of the other speakers and then they were
saying that you know backstage all the
speakers will hang out and stuff and he
just sits there Oh a bit miserable I
thought it was miserable but I just
think he's very intense isn't he's very
he's been in the game a long time and
he's you've seen a lot of people come
and go I mean he is written the Rich Dad
Poor Dad yeah the number one personal
developer yeah it's so you know sold
more copies been around for 20 years to
a massive hit today still as many every
day so he's a legend really
but he's got some very good insights to
what's going on in the world yeah well
so during the interview Samuel and I
signing I was pressing him on on
investments and stuff like that and what
one of the things one of the things that
he said that I thought you know will be
interesting for us to talk about on this
show was that he predicts in fact quite
a lot of what he was talking about was
he predicts a major market crash very
soon now he has been saying this in all
fairness for a few years well he was he
said at last you in South Africa when I
when I attended his event in South
Africa I seen the same thing so
obviously I think it's coming I don't
think it's gonna be the Armageddon that
he sort of is letting on well the truth
is is that we do get crashes it's it's
recession expansion and recession
expansion we've seen that throughout you
know so to say there's not gonna be a
market crash would be would be naive
especially considering everything we've
got going on at the moment with breck
say you love break set and I know I just
found an interest in that when he was
speaking he literally it would the way
he was talking was like the world will
end
it is like Armageddon is coming that's
how it was coming across yeah so I
imagine there's a lot of people left out
that dinner like thinking oh my god were
doomed like what the heck is that's what
it was like but one of the things he was
saying that was interesting is if you if
you know correctly how to invest and if
you're not stupid with you because he
was also talking about money becoming
kind of worthless and you should be but
just leaving in the bank yeah and we all
know you know fifty thousand pound in
the bank how much is he gonna be worth
in ten years ten years yeah less
precisely less yeah it is but quite a
bit less he was talking a lot about that
and he thinks the money where
everything's going digital everything's
that yeah physical cash you know the
pound sterling is gonna be it's gonna be
shrinking and it you should be investing
in all you've gotta do is look at it we
are becoming a cashless society only I
never carried you don't joke and I dunno
you don't carry cash cuz whenever we've
worked for a drink or meal you like
cannot can I tell them a funny story
about you carrying cash that we were
talking about yesterday huh right so
this this this guy came up to worry
we're in
in London and this guy come up to us I'm
assuming a homeless guy and he was like
I'm really poorly I need 20 pounds to
get to hospital do you have any any cash
and he asked me and Samuel Alastair was
you know a little bit away and I was
like really sorry cuz I but if I do have
cash I do tend to give him those sores
iterations as long I'm really sorry I I
don't have I don't have any cash and you
know he was like please we felt sorry
for the guy so Samuel was like hey has
anyone got any cash for this for this
guy sort of announced to everyone there
was there was a group people there and
Alice Alastair was like yeah yeah I have
right we were trying organized attacks
in stuff he killed he comes over reached
his pocket pulls out three grand just
right honestly it was like a what wedge
of cash this big text of 20 off doesn't
even look at the guy just hands in the
20 the guys like ah thank you yeah
whatever right oh I got a redeem myself
yeah cuz in fairness that's not exactly
how it went down
I'll tell you what happened there was a
homeless guy I believe yeah I don't
actually remember 20 quid ego yeah no no
no okay so what happened was I was
trying to sort a kappa and Samuel just
said to me Elsa have you got 20 quid so
I didn't know it was for a homeless guy
and then I literally I did I went into
my pocket pulled some money out took 20
quid off and I handed I just handed it
out thinking I was handed Samuel and
then I saw the homeless guy but okay you
guys thought it was a little bit harsh
and the guy was like trying to thank me
now I I just wasn't paying attention so
mr. homeless man I love you I hope
you're well I hope you won't spend that
too dependent on drugs and booze what's
funny about it that what was funny is
that like most people would either just
be like now I'm gonna money or let go
and then they would want the
appreciation because you know they would
feel like that they giving it out of
heart you didn't do i but now I know why
now it's you've given into Samuel but
you you were just like yeah ego 20 clip
whatever just it was just I thought it's
because I'm I'm I'm a giver I like to
give something you're a receiver you
like to receive the praise anyway so um
where were we oh yeah cash becoming
worthless yeah do that a few thing but
major market crash what Robert was
saying was in a in a crash that's when
you can actually make me you can make
money you can make money both times you
can make money in a crash can also make
money when yeah what robert promotes is
beat cash being worth that he talked
about fake fake money or like fake
teachers ie like talk like you talking
referring to like school teachers
because they're not teaching you the
correct ways of the world he talks a lot
about fake stuff and he says about cash
instead of having cash and bank you
should have it in assets and good that
bad there all that sort of stuff but see
he buys a lot of he buys a lot of
property but he also buys a lot of like
gold and silver oil
I always think with property as long as
you're happy to hold on to it yeah he
kind of pretty safe I think I agree with
you because you're never you and yo you
will never really lose on property if
when you sell it so if it's gone down
and say anything stocks shares property
anything if you buy it for a hundred
thousand pound and hold on to it and
then it drops to 80 thousand pound that
only becomes a problem
if you're selling it if you're selling
it if you're gonna hold it because you
got good tenants paying cash every month
in cash flow is it a massive deal but it
all depends on your strategy if you're
in for instance if the buy refurbish
refinance strategy might be a bit a bit
a bit dangerous any but it wouldn't be
damaged even that wouldn't be dangerous
if you were prepared to hold on to the
property yeah it but by refocus
refinance or buy refurbish and flip so
yeah actually buy refurbish flip to be a
little bit dangerous buy refocus we
fellas would be okay because one you
might I might not be able to find it
might be a case of five
refurbish it make bit kiss and then
resign now it's not getting buried at
the right moment five years down the
line yeah so you're right you're right
you lose the money when you sell yeah so
as long as you're as long as you make
sure that you're leaving yourself you're
not Vaughn you're not overstretching
you're not because we talk about
leverage a lot and leverage is brilliant
but you don't wanna over leverage yeah
because if you over leverage and then
there's a crash yeah then you are
screwed a lot of the big companies that
you do we see that go down go down
because they over leverage things go
wrong and they and they can't they can't
Selena to pay their debts
let's take companies that are just like
um new startup businesses things that
were they just over spend too much money
they'll let you overspend and everything
so they make a bit money they spend it
make a bit money spend it yeah and then
the out they've got nothing left in the
port and then when that we D happens
they've not got an umbrella yeah so yeah
there might be a crash but here's the
thing right here's his two things
history shows us a there's gonna be
crashes be after we crash we're gonna
expand again absolutely so even there's
a bad crash it will go up in property
prices 'im it's always always always
going up where money is always always
always going down yeah and the thing is
do you think forget about the markets
for a minute whether they go up or go
down I think that's a relevant because
if you have the correct education you
will make money no matter what's
happening yeah there was more there was
more millionaires made during the 2008
property crash than ever before one
because they know what they're doing
hmm and the the market crash so another
popular market crash there was more
people made more money than do you not I
mean there's Latvia lost money of course
but there was more millionaires made in
that period of time just because they
know what they're doing so when you know
what you're actually doing you can make
money when the markets are crashing you
just gotta know what you're doing so
again that comes that that's that comes
down to education would you say uh would
you what would you say then was your
biggest takeaway from meeting Robert you
know we had a chat with him what would
you say was your biggest ever Samuel
asked him a question if he was to start
again with with a hundred thousand
dollars or pounds what would he do with
that
though he was very I would say he's a
little bit big in the answer he
basically said I wouldn't wouldn't need
a hundred thousand francs I wouldn't use
he's an advocate of not using his own
money he's very proud of the fact that
and all of his property investments
none of his money is in that properties
or under properties so basically his
advice was just do what you want do do
what needs to be done so if there's are
if there's a need for something fill
that need so it's not a case of doing
what you love doing it's a case of doing
what you see needs to be done and adding
value to it so yeah that's that's that
was your biggest takeaway I mean there
was other stuff but that was fine if it
was but so your biggest takeaway is just
do what needs to be done do it I do like
that saying actually because too many
people focus on when they're starting a
business focus on what what the really
really like what they want to do which
is fine but that may not necessarily the
best business if you're looking to make
a business that grows into a very
successful business you've got to fill a
void haven't you there's got to be
you've got to fill a need in the market
that's got yeah well I very much find
out and fill that then I think you're
gonna be very much believe the more that
you know money is a certificate of value
yeah so the more value that you are the
more money that you the more money that
you'll make so rather than look what I
think kind of what he's saying it is and
correct me if I'm wrong with what what I
take from it is rather than s so it's
you know thinking what could make money
how can I have money had it how can I
add value yeah and as a result all I
think people when they first start and
business are so focused on making their
money they're so focused on like I need
to make money as quick as possible I
don't think that's a long-term
sustainable business I think you don't
do that I think I think personally you
should I focus on film that void and
adding value to people because when you
when you add value to people and you
give and you give a service or a product
or something that gives other people
what they want
ultimately you're gonna get paid but I
think a lot of people and we're a lot
people wrong with new businesses is the
soft they're so focused on Aaron and act
that money to pay them the bills each
month they don't necessarily do the
right business I think what I think
what's what I think when you when you
look desperate it's what you trying to
put in money I think people smell it
yeah
whereas when they feel that you're being
you're looking to add the value then
they're happy more happy to buy and
you'll get more you make more money in
the end because when you add an immense
value to somebody the price tag doesn't
come into it as much does it no if
you're running if you're if you're
adding it means vowed somebody and the
you you're helping them achieve what
they want to achieve you're helping them
get what they want then the price tag
can be whatever you choose to put on it
one of the things I teach it
winner sales intensive yeah is it's
never price it's always value yeah
because if I turn around to you let's
let's say you told me you couldn't
afford ten thousand pounds yeah
but I turned to you and said you're
gonna die if you don't go on you'd
suddenly melt find the ten thousand
heroin yeah it's because the value is
worth more than the ten thousand pound
I actually liked your winner I've liked
your winner sales intensive day I think
it's a very good day
so yeah kudos who knows yeah I want to
come one day and because I was busy but
one day I came it was very good wasn't a
delegate just pops it I just I just come
in to see you know I say you know I know
Oh anyway but not it sounds really bad I
don't know oh I'm not normal but I know
all your course that you run you know
and it's very yeah it's a very very good
course
so listen anyone thinking about that you
need to get in touch man because it's no
I don't know it just has to sell that no
no I'm not seeing that but it's not it's
not it's all about roses nor about quick
how to air a couple a couple up a couple
of quid it's not about that you have to
add vow to everybody yeah I say this
even with like my business but better
sauce we're finding investors like for
the the the deals that we have I get so
many messages regular and it's people
say no how do you find investors how'd
you find investors and I'm like great
well what value you add into your
investors why would they come to you you
have to if you want to find investors
you have to add vowed to them like so I
have a whole thing I go through and it's
all about adding bout and for asking for
money off them because you need they
need to know like and trust you yeah and
they're not going to know they can trust
you if the first thing you do is say
yeah that's too
or you need to actually the you need to
build trust in to build our knowing and
and you need them to like you yeah so I
think that's that's crucial you must add
lie before you sell on pain about it so
you find the need focus on the needs
fill that void focus on it add vow to
their lives the money will come
yeah and now that's one thing I took
away from robot ROM is talk yeah and
yeah he's he's obviously a very
successful man he's obviously very
wealthy so yeah
what I'm saying my biggest takeaway I
mean again it's tough it's tough
sometimes you already know but she just
gets reinforced like that you already
know that but it's just not it's nice
how it reinforced and you go yeah and
sometimes gives you a fresh perspective
of it I would say the biggest standout
thing for me seeing him there was the
fact that he totally surrounds himself
with mentor even though he could he
could think on Robert Kiyosaki I I don't
need a mentor on I am the ultimate yeah
they didn't even even really say it I
just noticed by hanging around with him
he's got his tax advisor with him he's
got he's mentor he's got that any
continue just surrounds himself with
people then that helped him yeah and
it's the the thing of however good you
are don't be too proud to have a mentor
to ask for help to get the right people
in and it's sort of made me think maybe
maybe I need to do that more I mean I
know I do I do have you know obviously
we're in the environment we've got great
people around us but maybe I need to do
that even more we've talked about this
before where I'm amazed like just
surrounding yourself with the right
people you surround yourself a five
douche bags then you're gonna be the six
you fail you surround yourself for five
successful people you gonna be a six mmm
it's all about and they even Robert
Kiyosaki does this and he is super super
successful yeah and it's great but it's
not just his friends he hires people in
as well all the time for every area he's
got a different he's got this guy that
guy live a guy he doesn't they well I
know I'm on the genius here no but they
you the day you say you're the genius
that you know all is the day I think you
start going downhill because nobody
knows all and Robert Kiyosaki even
he doesn't know all and that's why he
brings in mentors and brings in people
to help him they know where like tax
that's why he has that like that tax guy
yeah because he doesn't know that in the
fill the lt''s of time no it's very very
much it was very interested I enjoyed it
I know Samuel enjoyed the this the the
interview gnam yeah so it was very very
interesting like you know someone like
that you're always gonna let you always
gonna learn stuff Raman yeah he said I
know he's a big advocate for investing
in property yes and I did like I said I
do think property it's not crash proof
because it does get affected by the
crash but like you said it's about when
you sell mm-hmm and if you make sure
you're not vulnerable and you're you
sell on your terms they nothing then
you're gonna be okay I think - couple
key things to take away from the whole
thing is yes the the may well be
unlocked also calm good what a great
time to buy property yes especially
breaks at the lumen in the crash because
everyone oh yeah yeah and because
they've all unthinking and everyone's
scared because the media talks is
already different but in a crash that's
when you buy because my sizzle oh what's
the scene what's that scene when
everyone's being what's it when
everyone's greedy you should be it's not
saying it's just something Samuelson
okay so yeah when everyone's scared yeah
oh no no it's not time when everyone's
scared that's when that's when you want
to be greedy
yeah when everyone's greedy yeah if it's
in the news it's already like it's blast
bro I love the fact that's in the news
because it means there's lots of Lando's
out there and lots of people out there
that are if there is wouldn't if there
is a crash and everyone's cell in its
turn then that's the time maybe you
should be fine Yeah right it's now time
for this
[Music]
okay so in the news this week
Alistair's found and an interesting art
I think it's interesting so let me just
tell you the the the headline is in The
Guardian
so basically no rogue landlords have
been issued with banning orders in the
last 12 months which I found quite
shocking well what are things it what
things interesting about this is they've
brought in all these all these changes
in legislation and all this new
licensing and all this sort of stuff and
then they've don't use it okay so let me
just read the first call the paragraphs
so not a single rogue landlord has been
issued with one of the government's new
banning orders a year after the key new
power in the battle to root out the
country's worst rental property owners
was launched new laws which took effect
in April 2018 means that slum landlords
handed one of the new bands by the
courts are prevented from letting out
houses across England their details must
be entered onto the central government's
new rogue landlord database for local
authorities you won't wanna be on that
list
know what that's like you're officially
a rogue laughs yeah I just don't see the
point why bring the law out if they're
not going to enforce it although in all
fans when you consider and you know I
say you wouldn't want to be on it yeah
if you were the only person in a mess
even what's that would be quite cool
wouldn't it do you know the UK seventy
million people loads loads I and the
only Road laughs well the government
have estimated that there's ten and a
half thousand yeah ten a thousand rogue
landlords operating in England and
previously said when he annoyed
announced the law that they would be
expecting at least 600 of them to be on
that database and in 12 months time not
one person's on that database they've
had four they've had four em for what
way anointing what is the point do you
know I reckon she's job creation it's
just creating jobs people intern so
they're not gonna force it why do I
bring out it's pathetic
because all we ever hear about in the
media and all sorts as a rogue landlords
slum landlords but if they've got an
order they've got a banning order but
then
they're not using it so what is the
point and even making these laws up it's
I think it's pretty criminal to be
honest but why go to the airport and the
cost and there's never a rogue MP's list
yes all the MPs that make rules that
then useless the thing is the one less
than that allowed to make laws anymore
they wouldn't play any of them on there
would they it just be another one it
would I think I think this is letting
down everybody this is letting down good
landlords it's letting down tenants it's
letting down responsible people because
it's not letting down rogue landlords no
it's not random letting on him but it's
letting down the good people because I'm
a good landed you're a good landlord
Samuel is a good landlord right we would
never be on these lists but it's just
it's really annoying because we are
trying to strive we're striving to get
the industry high in the good and then
the government bring us a nice plan I
would say we're all thinking great I
don't mind that we're not scared of
change we're not scared of this sort of
all the rule and laws who we are who are
sort of they should be worried nothing's
happening if they know there's ten and a
half thousand rogue landlords how do
they know that they've estimated is 10
and 1/2 thousand estimated by what
doesn't say but I would assume by the
amount of complaints again then why
can't when they get a complaint why
can't they just do string about it I
don't know counsel but I would imagine
imagine it's some sort of budget cuts so
they haven't got the staff to follow up
it's like the the hate jamm or laws that
came in last October 2018 so they
brought the new licensing laws out to
roll that out it's gonna take a couple
of years so there's areas in the country
where they a law that you have to have a
license
nothing's gonna happen for years because
they haven't got the staffing to do it
they haven't got the budget to do it to
enforce it so and I know there's plenty
of and I know there is its laws of Haiti
more properties out there six seven
sorry five people in there over three
stories and they've no know what license
so but if we're a stage where it's like
yeah we got the laws but we but the
government and the police we can't
afford to actually enforce the laws well
what results like gonna have just matter
of you know banner keynotes what's gonna
happen I'm getting again I mean that's
the real first I just think if you're
gonna make a rule if you're gonna
for something enforcer if you're gonna
make a rule enforcer and we make rules
in the office what do we do and force
them we know we tell them about budget
cuts so we can't enforce them no so that
if we tell all the staff they've got to
be at work on time and they start a nine
o'clock and they turn in late what do we
do we enforce the rules we say look why
were you late we hold them accountable
yeah if we're late why are we late we
hold us our self accountable you're
right make a real stick to it end of
you're right
it's a horrible the government oh again
let us down anyway it's now time for
this
[Music]
okay so it's now time for your questions
and answers and we had an income throw
we've had Lourdes so yeah thanks very
much guys for asking the questions and
the property investors with Simon leads
page do look out for this every week we
do a Facebook live and get your
questions in so the first question is
from Chris Powell and it says hi can
Russell explain how he got started I've
been told to fall or how you got started
and implement myself if I can okay so
what's a question for you my friend I
wonder I wonder who told him that
maybe I recognized the name so I'm
wondering if he's been on what I think
Chris is on the Academy and I think he's
he was as a launchpad okay well I have
talked about the first dealer that I did
did before I didn't have very much money
and I managed to borrow the money for a
deposit and I then put the deposit down
bought the house and I you paid off that
he popped the the loan I got for the
deposit I've paid off over five years
and the same time was I was also paying
the mortgage off which meant that I
basically broke even I made a little bit
of money but then by the time he took
off a few costs and stuff I basically
broke even for the first five years and
[Music]
that was it was okay and then after five
years I started making okay cash flow
from but that was my first property
that's what I did borrowed the money
bought the property basically bought it
for free didn't make very much money out
of it but it has gone up about
twenty-five grounds yes not made I've
made money off capital appreciation not
a massive amount it's been a slow is
this that property that's had the same
tenants as he never heard from a relief
now that's that the the next deal I did
was a buy refurbish refinance steal so I
don't know what I would I would say I'm
I'm not sure I would we really teach the
method that I used to begin so what will
you buy refurbished refinance well if
you had to give if you had to give Chris
three steps to follow your footsteps
what would to be
um three steps to follow in my footsteps
as a property investor or a tired to get
started in everything
yeah gone let's just - it's very cushy
situation I mean that's how I got
started so it depends if he's got money
is he got cash flow coming in what if I
was getting started completely from
scratch so let's say I was doing a
financial freedom challenge and you
dumped me somewhere I would probably do
deal packaging mm-hmm as a way of making
money yeah
so I'd say I'd set up a business I set
up a deal packaging business to bring
money and I would use that money to
invest in in property so that's our
business to make money and fiber
starting again I'd want to get some cash
flow coming in I enjoy working so I'm
not someone that's a desperate to be
just about some income straight away
well sorry but if you've got no money
you kind of can't just get a passive
income straight away it's kind of unless
well even if you get due to like a lease
option agreement you've got to work to
get that it's not going to just it's all
just gonna happen it's not just a step
one would be to create a business that
deal packaging business to create income
step to be to use that income to the
best to invest and start creating a
passive income and then I got a choice
then I can either if you want you could
over deal selling business and just live
off your passive income or what I would
do is I would grow the deal selling
business earn more money invest more
money have a bigger passive income and
the money coming in from the deal
packaging and grow it like this yeah I
think that's a pretty good answer so
hopefully that helped Chris I was
starting up from scratch okay next
question from Tom Clark
hi guys keep killing it and doing what
you're doing ah thanks man what is the
most effective and reliable way to find
director vendor deals and I shall see
you the next week's DfE if you're there
yes we are going to be the uthia yeah
yeah we're gonna be that DfE next week
I'll be there and Ross will be there
alright so director minute deals base it
off for me I'll give warning and you can
give some for me so places like Gumtree
yeah gun fees very good is that is the
best okay I do this Lots with better
source so Gumtree we use all the time
Facebook find lots of deals on Facebook
just little things like do you know when
you're out and about talk to people so I
would have been London or week
and I got and I was in cabs all the time
I was always talking to the taxi drivers
and telling telling them what they do
and things out so just talk to people
now I think any deals that we came from
taxi drivers but it's very interesting
because when you start speaking to
people you realize that you just don't
know what they've got and what they are
and who they are I don't know there
might be a landlord that just drives a
cab for the weekends and he's never
known you talking to so speak there's
many people you can I was trying to
someone at the weekend was not didn't
get popped out it turns out slight no
not a major but a pop star yes yep I was
trying to her and then she was like oh I
said what do you do then and she said
I'm a singer-songwriter okay I said
where can I see your stuff like Spotify
yeah looked her up
five million listens and stuff on songs
and so I heard you wrote yeah write
write songs for people like you know
Bruno Mars but you I've never known that
without game you just by looking at it
or even just briefly talking to him but
you like you say always be networking
you never know people probably talk to
people at your local your local sort of
corner shop your Indians your takeaway
to Chinese restaurants any any that
kebab shop because that's just an excuse
isn't it
yeah yeah I mean you can have an Indian
plate anything kebab whatever I'm
looking at you I can tell that you're
very good at that sort of networking
nice thanks fat talks again okay all
right anyway so just chat to everybody
because you don't know what they've got
so Gumtree facebook chat to everybody
adverts and local papers pizza shops
kebab shops Indian shops Chinese shops
because I can actually get this shirt on
and it's loose now so late list of the
fat jokes right okay well that's what
Brad's a Brad's rat heart hey guys hope
your ads heart that he sounds like he
sounds like a WWE wrestler he does how
she like Bret the Hitman Hart so Brad
the Hitman Hart hey guys hope you oh
yeah we a fight we are awesome buddy
hope you are too
I already have parents that
good okay it's again I already have
periods with to buy delayed properties
so it's the way you read it I know
anything to say Brad Damon are ferrets
right I already have parents with to buy
too late properties with another in the
pipeline awesome yeah I want to go down
the route of rent to rent and lease
option agreement is it best having a
basic contract being already written up
and being completed knowledgeably of
each aspect on there okay basics okay no
rent no kind of rent to rent yes it
needs to be done properly you need a
solicitor to do it in the first place
all by one or by one and then you can
edit that to suit the property lease
options one percent of times solicitor
yeah know that you've been or never use
a template for a lease option agreement
I turn there's lots of saris give you
actually work Nick but he's gonna put a
link up to that now on the screen we
just show talking a lot about lease
options and we explain why but lease
options for your benefit that their
benefit but mainly for your benefit you
need a proper contract rent to rent it's
fine as long as you need to prop a
contract but you don't need a new
warrant as list to every single time no
great I agree brilliant guys thanks ever
so much for watching the show really
hope you enjoyed it will back next
Saturday at 7 p.m. so do not forget to
tune in please subscribe to the channel
there's content every single day it's an
amazing channel and we will see you next
week see you next week guys
[Music]
[Applause]